my next guest is one of the most
controversial figures in recent American
history KL writtenhouse pleed
self-defense when he was charged with
murdering two people during the
Wisconsin black lives matter RI of 2020
and the jury agreed for some ritten
house has become a heroic standard
Bearer The Second Amendment and
Americans rights to bear arms for others
he got off because of privilege now two
years after his trial ended he's written
a book called acquitted to tell his side
of the story and he joins me now live
from Florida car rhous thank you very
much indeed for joining me um first of
all let me just ask you if you had your
time again would you age 17 have put an
AR-15 semi-automatic rifle around your
neck and gone purposefully down to where
these protests were happening knowing
what was going to
transpire well Pierce thank you for
having me on with hindsight being 2020
as it always is no I wouldn't have gone
but that doesn't change the fact that I
was attacked and I defended myself I was
there to help people and provide first
aid and and that's what I did I'm on
video that night providing first aid and
helping people and then being ambushed
and cornered and forced to use my rifle
to defend myself you killed two people
and you wounded a third how do you feel
about
that well Pierce they attacked me they
left me with no choice I have nightmares
every night of being attacked and being
ambushed and them trying to steal my gun
and pointing guns in my face it's not an
easy thing to do but I did what I had to
do to stay alive and if I didn't I would
be dead yeah listen you were acquitted
and many in America believe that you had
the absolute right to defend yourself
I'm just curious on a human level you
know you're very young even now what are
you 20 years old
now yes sir and and you've killed two
human beings and wounded a third I just
wonder how that
feels I don't think that's an
appropriate question ask how it feels
it's not an easy thing to do it's
something I live with every single day
it's nightmares I have it's something
that I have to deal with I have to deal
with the PTSD and the trauma from having
to do
that right I mean but it seems to me
your emotions are more about you and
your trauma because your life was being
threatened and and that side of it
rather than the question I'm asking
which is simply on a human level how do
you feel about being so young and yet
having on the record for the rest of
your life now that you took the lives of
two people regardless of the
circumstances
and and like I just said it's something
I deal with every day I deal with the
PTSD and the trauma and the nightmares
it's not easy to deal with
it your book um presumably you're going
to make money from this book do you feel
comfortable making money from from this
which ultimately is a a tragic story um
you know I again I repeat you requ it
there's no reason you can't do a book
but do you feel comfortable making a lot
of money out of essentially what in the
end was an incident that cost the lives
of other
humans well I'm not writing the book to
make money I'm writing the book to tell
the story of what happened I'm telling
trying to change the narrative that
media keeps putting out there that I'm
some type of white supremist racist
person when that's just not true I'm a
20-year-old kid who was put in a
situation to where I was forced to
defend myself and I'm writing to put
that into aook I wrote to put that I
wrote a story and put that in a book so
I can share that with everybody so they
can understand what I went through how
my childhood was growing up and the
difficulties I deal with today and you
can check out the book at Rittenhouse
book.org if you want to read it and
learn the truth for yourself how do you
feel that you became a hero to many on
the far right kind of made you their
poster
boy well Pierce I'm not a hero I did
what I had to do to to defend myself
there are countless Americans every day
that defend themselves and it's not a
heroic thing to do it doesn't make you a
villain but it doesn't make you a hero
it's doing the right thing to to stay
alive if I didn't if I didn't defend
myself I wouldn't be here talking today
you were 17 at the time you were too
young to legally acquire the gun that
you used that's not true it's not
true that is not true Wisconsin statute
says a person under between the ages of
16 17 can car can carry a long rifle
with a barrel longer than 16 inches
that's Wisconsin law and the judge
dismissed that charge okay so you would
leave let me ask you look I I'm in the
country right now and I've talked about
this many times both here and in America
and I learned Americans want to handle
their own gun culture the way they want
to handle it I respect that but let me
ask you do you think it's right
that 17year olds in America in Wisconsin
should be able to carry around
semi-automatic rifles like an
AR-15 our founding fathers were very
intentional when they wrote the
Constitution they didn't put an age
limit on how old you have to be to um
exercise the Second Amendment but they
did say it would be part of a
well-regulated
militia they also didn't put an age in
it and we have the right to bear arms
it's our right as Americans to to
possess these arms to carry these AR
these firearms and to use them to
protect ourselves how do how do people
treat you Carl when you when you walk
around
there well there there is some
harassment um I'm constantly having
photos taken of me I'm constantly
receiving death threats on social media
and it's just something that is part of
my life now having pictures taken of me
everywhere I go and the constant
constant harassment and death threats
obviously by doing a book and promoting
it in the way that you are on National
Television around the world you're going
to make yourself even more famous
Infamous whatever you want to call it um
is that is that something you're aware
of that you're deliberately consciously
doing
that I'm aware that it's going to bring
some more notoriety to my name and make
me more known but I think it's worth
that risk to share my story and share
what happened just in the hopes that
maybe somebody who else somebody else
who goes through a similar situation or
faces other trials in their life they
can read it and they can understand that
they're not alone and that this happens
to other people with the misjustice that
does happen in America okay K
writtenhouse thank you for joining me I
appreciate
it